el primer ministro sabe que la ley de
mercado interno de estas cláusulas
polémicas sobre irlanda del norte que
mencionas son su asma bajo la manga para
ganar le el pulso a la unión europea
para obtener el mejor acuerdo posible
especialmente en derechos de pesca que
han sido uno de los polémicos en toda
esta negociación y que ha generado el
estancamiento de estas es cierto voto
por mayoría el parlamento pero cierto y
no el ministro así no quiere puede
porque está la ley todavía está en
trámite definitivo retirarlos y entonces
si se llega a un acuerdo esto podría
suceder
por ello boris johnson insiste en que
quiere el mejor acuerdo posible para el
reino unido pero también está presionado
por los euroescépticos de su partido que
quieren impedir en realidad se abre
éxito y las relaciones de la unión
europea déjense de ser tan cercanas no
se ha confirmado cuando boris johnson
viajar a bruselas pero lo cierto es que
también que hacerlo antes de este jueves
porque se reunirán los líderes de la
unión europea para su última